guys how we doing welcome to good works
tractors i'm asked all the time
why do i need a snow plow snow pusher or
anything else
i've already got a bucket on the front
of my tractor what's wrong with just
using that
and yeah it's going to remove snow it's
going to push it it's already there it's
convenient it's paid for
move that snow where you want to be done
with it simple as that
every attachment is built for certain
tasks set a pallet forks
a grapple a tiller a brush hog and just
because
it's on the front of your tractor right
now doesn't mean that it's suited or
intended
to move snow there's a lot of reasons
why a bucket is not good for snow
removal let's get into that now
if you like what you see here would you
do me a big favor give me a thumbs up on
this video and if you'd like to see
future videos like this one
hit that subscribe button right down
below if you're in the market for
tractor accessories or attachments
maybe even a tractor itself read through
the description below or go to good
works tractors you'll find all sorts of
cool products for tractor owners like us
now don't get me wrong i love tractor
seat time just as much as anybody else
however
it can be frustrating and annoying
especially if it's freezing cold out and
you're in an open station tractor
to not get the job done quickly so with
that being said you take a look at the
design the construction
of a bucket from the front of your
tractor could be a skid steer too
the point being it's designed with a
bottom back sides
to trap and hold material whether that's
dirt it could be mulch it could be rock
it could be snow but the point is is
that it's gonna keep it inside there and
not let it go
without an effort from the operator so
with a snow pusher or a snow plow
you're driving forward pushing that snow
wherever you want to and when you got it
to that point where you want to leave it
there
all you do is just start backing up
maybe raise the loader up a little bit
and away you go
the same can't be said with a bucket
with a bucket again that snow wants to
stay in here
or whatever material it is so you have
to lift that bucket up
you have to rock it forward you have to
shake it out there's still going to be a
lot of snow trapped in these corners
here that's overall going to make it a
very inefficient tool
just from that aspect so if you take a
look at the snow pusher right here and
it could be a plow as well it's the same
concept
you'll notice there's no bottom there's
no floor there's nothing to trap and
hold material in it
that's the big difference between a
bucket and a pusher so
when you're moving that pile of snow
forward you just simply back up and it's
going to stay there
one push is no big deal but push after
push after push
and then every time you go out and plow
and then season after season that's a
ton of additional time that you're
spending just on
shaking a bucket to empty the material
out one of the ways that i've seen i've
read online
to kind of help snow release and maybe
not get stuck in these corners is going
to be using
some sort of a spray you know a
lubricant silicone teflon
pam even but just sprayed all inside
here i've kind of seen mixed results
i'm pretty sure i even saw a thread on
one of the tractor forms where a guy did
a test with and without the teflon or
silicone spray inside of the snow blower
didn't really see much of a difference
in the result but overall i think
it didn't do any harm so maybe it'll
help you maybe it won't but it's
something to look at
if you're going to use your bucket
another consideration with the design of
a bucket here is going to be this bottom
edge that comes along here
not only is that going to trap and hold
material that's in here and not allow it
to release
but it also means it's intended to dig
dig down
dig into a pile whatever material it is
again gravel dirt
mulch it could be any of the above but
the point being
is that as this is riding along that
plowing surface it's going to want to
naturally just dig
into whatever that surface is if you
have gravel stone
even asphalt or a concrete surface you
catch any edges on there or loose stone
it's gonna maybe chip an edge collect
that stone put it into your yard
somewhere you don't want it
so you can see a bucket right here with
a long edge designed to dig
compare it against a plow right here
it's going to have skid shoes tucked
underneath the bottom or if you have a
snow pusher you'll have skid runners on
either end that are going to prevent
this main leading edge here from digging
down into the ground
the intent is to just kind of glide
along with those skid shoes or the skid
runners
not dig down but just follow that
surface there the contour of it take
care of the snow and move that where you
want to
so that's something very important to
consider because that could end up
costing you a lot of additional money
repairing that damaged surface down the
road
if you're concerned about costly repairs
to the surface you're plowing whether
it's a gravel drive concrete asphalt
the same thing can be said for your
bucket as well because this edge right
here
is going to wear significantly and
unevenly meaning you're not going to be
able to use it very well for other
digging purposes that it's really
intended for
this edge right here is going to end up
rounding off at the corners here
you'll see a lot of significant wear
chewing up the main portion of this wear
edge
and then it'll come back in and die off
into these side plates right here
and once you get to that point you're
really making it unusable however if you
really want to use your bucket or maybe
it's just a temporary solution until you
can figure out a better long-term
solution
there's some things you can do to
prevent that uneven and unnecessary wear
on your bucket edge
[Music]
you're going to see a couple of
different products right here one is
going to be
essentially a type of skid shoe that you
can put onto your bucket
just kind of fit it on there like that
and it's going to keep it from
allowing the main bucket edge here to
make contact with that plowing surface
both protecting your plowing surface and
the bucket itself
the trade-off is going to be the fact
that your bucket is then going to be
oh maybe three quarters or an inch above
the plowing surface
therefore leaving a significant amount
of snow behind
another option you can look into is
something like this poly or uhmw
is called a cutting edge that you can
put onto your bucket
kind of mount it down underneath here
and make this the sacrificial edge
instead
not only is poly a good option for that
but this is very protective
of paved surfaces as well anything like
your asphalt or your concrete
a good way to sum up uhmw is that it's
going to cut like steel but protect like
rubber
now some buckets are going to come
pre-drilled which this bucket here was
already pre-drilled you can see there's
actually an additional steel edge on the
bottom
a lot of smaller compact and sub-compact
tractors will not have a pre-drilled
bucket edge on here so you may have to
do a little bit of drilling on your own
in order to secure the uhmw now i will
have links below in the description of
the video if you want to get more
information on where to buy
skid shoes like this or the uhmw while
we're talking about edges on buckets
you know what i totally forgot i even
had this it's winter time you don't
think about it too much but this is a
really cool option for the summertime
it's going to be a way to enhance the
versatility and the digging capability
of your bucket instead of having this
smooth edge here you'll have these teeth
this whole bar here just tightens down
you have these allen
set screws here that just tighten down
it stays in place i honestly never take
mine off because it's that handy to have
when i need it but
something to take a look at this is a
heavy hitch tooth bar you go to their
website and order directly there
anything on their website you get five
percent off with code gwt so again i'm
not saying that a bucket is not going to
work for snow removal it certainly will
it's just that there are certain tools
that are meant to be used for snow
removal there are certain tools that are
used to be able to scoop and dig and
hold material
so they're two different things and
trying to use one for a different
purpose
it's gonna be kind of frustrating and
could end up being very costly for you
even if you're trying to save some money
up front it could cost you more down the
road so if you found this video helpful
consider giving me a thumbs up and also
if you haven't done so
subscribe to my channel by clicking that
button below and as always read through
that description
you'll get helpful information links on
where you can buy those products like
those skid shoes or the poly edge or
maybe a snow pusher or a replacement
bucket or a whole tractor we can put
together a whole package for you and
ship it to you as well
well until next time stay safe we'll see
you soon
right inside
let's go come on
have fun start over
you